garland Home Depot why plus a free
gettin holiday decor merry and bright
a flock to Christmas tree preferably
like shut and happy
what does that mean
means it has like snow on it well then
why when you get a tree with snow on it
what it's fly
walk walk
I think the title of this video is going
to be getting plot now we're in for you
yep
[Music]
it
Tiger tree he returned to a Chacon
freako oh wow let's go
where you going now bring and put a hat
on it it's quite frigid out here
although people from Pennsylvania are
like wow it's such a nice day out and
I'm like what
I'm freezing my body is for using my
pencil to fail the first time free where
we going free Christmas couch
yep comfy
I kinda needed
I just don't see a point decorating
purposes because I'm not even at my
house and it's just you gotta clean it
up bring it off get it
[Music]
oh boy
let's get out but would be freaked out
that - stop stop don't touch me - you
saw that's right at all just let me on
the box
father the box I need a couple extras
maybe some extra people will come home
look well
oh yeah get the napkins - forget those
napkins you got to get this big serving
platter yeah you got to get this big
bowl for the pretzels you got to get the
bowls for the shoe it be a cookie for
ladder
yes cookie platter that's for salad
salad salad to tell about the soup
tomorrow it's a long sorry
yeah you got to get the big serving bowl
- you gotta have to find pretzels some
chips of a salad see you what if they
cancel Christmas I'm sure you're stuck
with those discounted rate yeah Trump
said he's canceling Christmas no he
looks you want to serving platters
because what if you have two cookie
trays what's bed right where are we
gonna put the sandwiches no like you
should big you're kidding total isn't
anything that we say
let's just get one let's just get one we
should get to where are we gonna put the
sandwich maybe if she get to we should
get to get to where are we gonna put the
sandwiches should you get a third bowl
because where are we gonna put the
popcorn Hey look what I have to cut to
fit her here Dee has it we have that
home yes I got it at Secret Santa or
something so general got it the white
elephant from collie
[Music]
Starbucks drive-thru here we are here we
go free do you know what this is on the
dashboard think about it what does that
look like in wide-angle lens camera I'm
not sure what I want it Starbucks yet
it's a 360 camera so it can see the car
in front of us and you can see you I was
like excuse me do this no I mean in my
should have it you can see everything so
on YouTube you can just scroll around
that's better unless you're peeing or in
the bath and then you just see the floor
or beestings office what yeah you peed
in the bed
I hate pushing the cart because I can't
drink my Starbucks I need my phone in
time oh my god come over here
my god yes I do
like a brand regressing piece no
immediate area sure oh so sad it's
really sad so Susan I feel like you
could drink it
my princess super kidnet getting this
dumpster yeah slay me how do I see all
the things because Oh pity
both was going for a sweatshirt and
Maddie goes no you're not
he wants the Yoda onesie are you trying
to get my onesie okay you guys ready
yeah don't mind me I have to set up
Riggins phone while we're doing this
okay if I'm a little preoccupied okay
cool this is a good one who's your
biggest celebrity crush oh I know who it
is
wait wait for me yeah yeah joe flacco Oh
Joe Flacco hello call me maybe uh I
don't think that's your biggest biggest
slug it's my recent one so hair flip Wow
you're watching this dealer girl I don't
think I like your walk on weight with
this hell is he for me this is asking
every Hoosier I guess celebrity crush
you might have tiba ten Tebow I left it
deep I like I like Barry Allen from the
flash don't tell man Joe Flacco I love
the Steelers I just I'm just you know
I'm sorry to have your real instead of
my events phone brianne's getting my old
6s she's really upgrading with getting
technology what are some embarrassing
stories with each other
mm-hmm well one friend Justine pooped
her pants we're about to go to Vegas I
did
so our Brienne's Bachelorette prey yeah
yeah very alien would BRE ever move to
the west coast
she bought her dude cold here I don't
know maybe not saying Harrison Briana
planning on having any babies okay
soon I have a baby wait have you guys I
met my baby her this is my baby Bell
yeah he's a little he's a little weird
shy on camera no look at my baby you
know okay not about it you can have your
bone here he's not so much indigo by the
ocean who was the first one to bring a
boyfriend home to the parents how did it
go so much question mm a boy friends
what was your dream job as a child you
wouldn't be an astronaut wait you're not
dude we're not asking me to me you're
supposed to answer what you want I
wanted to be an architect and then I
realized I hated math and then I was
like I want to be a vet and then I
realized I don't want to do the bad
parts of being a vet so here I went to
be a kindergarten teacher
oh so sweet yeah Bri what's your
favorite USBC dongle thus far I don't
even know what that means
what's the USB dongle swapping the USB
dongle loving the USB my vision oh but
with it the huncle what's your best meal
that you had this year
that's um the homemade pierogies mmm
homemade pierogies were for real on you
and Daddy made we need to discuss the
meatloaf that I had at this restaurant
my mom made the meatloaf for me as well
I have the eggplant parmesan from also
the same restaurant and it was delicious
foolish are you guys gonna tell with our
Shauna's Oh secret secret can't go there
if you had one bag to fill with your
five most important possessions and
never see anything else again what would
you pass back well chapstick my beverage
you don't have email on your phone this
your weight the list
yeah I just cleared my inboxes yeah I
have to do two things at once cause Bri
has to leave us okay miss um so I would
fill it with a ammo feed chapstick
what was the question five items in the
bags
what would you take traffic might repeat
mow feet computer phone camera people
money okay then I'm gonna take my dog oh
yeah dogs were including the bag I
putting the dog in the back my phone
listen why would you take the dog and
not like mommy daddy sir
we have our own okay their home battery
well Matty doesn't give zoom back no
dogs I have to choose I'm gonna have to
take like us confuse we should further
on of you did the most chores at home
growing up Brianne probably she just
needs doesn't do her chores shouldn't do
anything don't kick him yeah you're a
liar I just block things make a lot of
messes though oh here's one is where you
gonna get a drone oh no what I need room
for I do not a gern now you take regular
pictures okay so in pretties other night
you drop not getting a turn okay who's
Melanie Martinez hmm geniune that is
yeah somebody says do you like them I
say oh what is this is this her email
huh two wheels you have to ena like
clear the might when I get them oh my
god Jenny folders Brianne cool yours out
her email which you get like can you
clear that one now would you like to see
what I have cuz that's fun night my
emails are like my to-do list so I have
a do that I need to pay you are done
that you leave it in more to know this
goes to trash and I have one of my junk
that I need to get rid of cuz I she's
got one in her junk junk junk junk
wanted my shot what what how was our
Christmas it was my light bulbs for a
Steiner back to work tomorrow
no does anyone have an earring in yes
here is amazing please please here we're
just phone hacks
let me clean it no shove it in there
thank you I know he's right you're using
hearing or if you don't have an earring
find something like a 9 1 o paperclip or
a safety picnic spit in a safe wall
paper clip might be a little big yeah
safety pin works so nicely huh
clean up further back in your hair no
it's ok that's real fresh films are not
dirty I just cleaned mine yeah
oh wait yours didn't get sewn soap on
top - ah foon soaped
here's my bows hi buddy I don't think
you can circus thank you
what matter you got shunned let's find
man didn't you picture myself a free
song I don't have a good nanny because
they said Jenna we can't have three dogs
when you come home and I'm like but I I
I'm the first one who love the animals
not these fools wait I aminals
I love aminals first goes out alright
thanks for watching guys thank you
thanks I going on my channel then things
jazz me Jimmy o'phelan her got my belly
[Music]